i want to i want to give uh this whole
story like from start to finish its own
opportunity so let's let's talk about
what's going on in media and then we'll
we'll make our way to the full story of
what's going on with j6 and everything
we have this tweet from michael malus
check this out because we're just
talking about facebook censorship so in
in light of that we have michael malus
tweeting spotify has deleted two of my
joe rogan appearances
michael did spotify delete it
did joe delete it
we don't know
he says both of the episodes are
pre-covered
this website checks for you so if you
head over to jremissing.com
you can see right right right at the top
gad sad gone
mike ward and pentel is gone michael
malus kyle kalinski tom segura michael
malus theo vaughn peter holmes wherever
it says new there are 71 episodes that
have been removed t.j kirk
aubrey marcus was the theo von one
recent
the uh theo von is uh not no i don't
think so it's 9 20. there were two then
there's there's a more recent one from
11 41 actually yeah so he had a recent
one pulled too well it was about a year
relatively recent like like gad sad was
you know 240 episodes ago so this is
quite some time ago like a year plus but
you can see all of these are removed on
the fourth spotify
has removed these episodes i think it's
fair to say but the question is why have
they removed them the point i was making
about michael malus is did joe agree
with these removals did he disagree with
them why are they removed and so far 113
episodes have been taken down now
this is joe rogan's show
he can do whatever he wants with it
right if he wants to take an episode
down fine here's here's the challenge
it's kind of strange that there are
there's a website dedicated to tracking
episodes of some dude's podcast
but the issue is as i was talking about
earlier the whole world is just conflict
everything pop culture is conflict now i
just want to curl up on the couch put on
some you know
dc
show or movie watch batman fight the
joker have some pizza and then wake up
in the morning and go just walk around
maybe go to restaurants and pancakes but
you can't do that anymore because you
turn on the tv everything's politics
everyone is politics everything
everything so what's happening is joe
rogan has become effectively you know
the tip of the spear one of the most
important cultural
information centers and it's not about
him telling you facts and stuff like
that's about him having conversations
that allow regular people to kind of
understand the world so when spotify
bends the knee or joe does to the woke
mob who won't let up as i've already
stated
when they when they announced the
misinformation policy and they gave a
grain of sand they're continually giving
ground to the left the left will not
stop what happens next the next day we
get announcement oh this podcast is
pulling obama is saying he's not going
to do anything anymore he's they're
angry the prince you know who is it
prince william and megan what's her face
they're like we're not going to make a
podcast either even though they haven't
and i'm like and then crosby stills and
nash and i'm like giving them what they
ask for doesn't make them stop now
spotify has pulled 71 more episodes
maybe it was joe who pulled them
regardless it's not going to make them
stop yeah you don't concede to the
demands of delusional idiotic crazy
people who just want to censor speech
and a lot of people don't just see this
as a podcast they see this as a last
stand for free speech and with these
latest developments i mean this is this
is troubling this website was started
because originally when joe rogan moved
from youtube to spotify there was
allegedly an error that was happening
with some of the more controversial
videos that and interviews that didn't
port over joe rogan made a statement
statement about this said that they
would port over they never did uh
there's this website now there's more
videos that are gone memory hold and no
longer in existence
and people are left with some very
serious questions that i think we should
have some answers to now again probably
joe rogan is going through a tremendous
amount of pressure um i could only
imagine what he's going through
behind the scenes of things that we
don't even know so
what's really happening here i don't
know but it's a troubling development
especially when 71 videos why one
podcast get why these episodes it's a
bunch of his friends i think it's
because he doesn't want to implicate
them in the drama no no no no
no
michael mouse has several appearances i
think is for only two get removed yeah
but this is ours and
hold on a minute if that were true he
didn't remove any of my episodes is he
trying to get me in trouble you're not
dramatic tim
you're so smooth and cool but i mean
it's it's a lot of it's a lot of
episodes it's 71 i think i honestly
think that this woke mob has been
satisfied
with taking down 71 episodes it's a lot
i don't think so that is fine i think
it's only at the beginning
it's a taste of blood and they want the
whole enchilada he didn't take down dr
robert malone he took down gad sad and
michael malus and kyle kalinski yeah and
sam sam tripoli brian redband uh ari
shafir no i wonder i i wonder if this
has more to do with what joe said on
those shows as opposed to what the
guests said
no definitely it is uh and and here's
the thing i was joking about that the
thing is that their target isn't joe
rogan episode number 1000 it's joe rogan
that they want to take out period right
and
i mean so many this is like we're so
behind the curve on this like we've been
screaming this
and i get why people don't like the
proud boys i completely understand and i
respect their decision not to like us i
get it but once they took alex down then
they took us down
right and they took down everybody in
between
uh
they're just not gonna stop and i think
we're getting to that point
where they're banning they're banning
the truckers on the other front they're
banning the truckers now and before that
they banned alex jones the proud boys
and everybody else in between we're
getting to the point where it's getting
so extreme
that
there's conversions coming from this
because
regular truckers are probably aren't
political now they're like okay they're
against my people now i'm gonna go uh to
the capitol yeah i think i know what
this is
when you go to jremising.com you can see
a big a big portion of all the new ones
it's it's when you get to the top they
start spacing themselves out like 963
925 there's a big gap of almost 40
episodes there then 9 12 then 100
episodes 8 10 to the next one right yeah
but you go down to the beginning
and it's like 4 20 21 27 40 42 48 50 55
57 66 72 that's back in the crude days
when they say whatever was saying
whatever
saying like there's a compilation people
have put out of him saying the n word
not using it
saying it there's compilations people
have made of him saying offensive things
i wonder if these episodes getting
pulled are because joe himself had said
things that crossed the line or are
today no longer consider politically
correct but even deleting them brings
more attention to these videos like i
think he's smart enough to understand
unless this was spotify that did this
but i think he's smart enough to
understand that if you if you try to
take something off of the internet and
hide it from the general public people
are going to go crazy and then talk
about it even more and obsess about it
because of that that aspect of getting
rid of it so that you know everything's
on on the internet is almost permanent
um especially when you try to hide it
and you have the streisand effect to
take place but here's a consequence with
that is
from now on it's getting watered down
and watered down and by the time that
you know it you're going to get a
completely watered down
jre podcast that is
like you're not even going to recognize
it anymore people mentioned this when
the first when the shift happened when
joe first moved over to spotify
there were some questions about whether
or not he was going to be edgier or
softer and a lot of people thought he
was going soft because then he started
doing these big celebrity interviews he
did i think like miley cyrus and he had
like robert downey jr
but
he had on peter mccullough and dr robert
malone he's had on alex jones i i don't
think he's gone soft at all however
with this latest massive move it's been
a month-long campaign against them and
they now pull 71 episodes when those
when that shift happened from youtube to
spotify the official statement we got i
think i think what joe said was that
youtube didn't archive a bunch of the
shows properly and you couldn't download
them that's that happens that that's
happened to us on several occasions when
you go into your youtube manager you can
take a stream and click download and for
some reason some of them you just can't
do it what you can do though is you can
do a hard record you can play the video
and then just screen record the whole
thing and capture it if you had to if
you had to there's probably other
there's probably other programs you can
get those programs
it's harder on live streams you can't
you can't just use like the auto
download video thing for them for some
of them but we were told they would get
put back up they never got put back up
this is different this is this is a
sustained uh campaign against joe and
then on one day on a friday evening all
at the same time 71 episodes
yeah i don't think they were expecting
people to know which ones like you were
saying it comes out if we hadn't done
this and talked about it
it's really subtle well stealth the way
they did it well when it first happened
and those episodes originally a couple
months ago were taken over during the
original
transfer between spotify
between youtube and spotify it was the
most controversial episodes that were
missing and accidentally not ported over
which left a lot of people asking some
serious questions that of course weren't
answered we also have to understand this
is on the heels of the u.s government
the biden administration putting
pressure on spotify british
royalty putting pressure on of course
spotify the same british royalty that
has connections and things with like
individuals like jeffrey epstein and and
all these other individuals so so we're
having a lot of very powerful
institutions whether blackrock or pfizer
or the us government or all these other
big financial players and multinational
corporations saying stop exposing the
agenda stop destroying the narrative we
need to
have our way with the general public you
informing them giving people informed
consent and having people think
critically about what we're doing to
them is not helping us you better stop
right now and this is an effort of of of
it being stopped here's what i want to
say though
he didn't take dr malone down he didn't
take mccullough down
i wonder if this might be joe saying
okay in these episodes i may have
crossed the line if i take these ones
down it protects my ability to do shows
in the future now hold on that being
said
these videos taking them down solves
nothing they still exist they're all
archived when the first episodes got
polled people in mass archived all of
his shows there's literally no point in
pulling these videos down the clips are
already out there the criticism is
already out there the shows have already
existed for a decade i don't see what
the logical reason is for removing onion
yeah i don't think joe did this i think
he would be a lot smarter because even
if he did do what you explained he would
have done it in a transparent way where
he would have made an announcement and
said hey i need to be a better person or
whatever or address or address it doing
it on a friday night doing it i think it
could either be some rogue spotify
employees because there was previous
accusations of rogue spotify employees
leaking private information and of
course having a vendetta against joe
rogan it could be spotify crumbling it
could be spotify sending a message it
could have been an error who knows we
don't know exactly what's happening here
we're just speculating and it's
important to understand that there has
been a tremendous amount of pressure put
on joe rogan and he doesn't just
represent a podcast he's not just an mma
guy that likes to talk about chimpanzees
he represents critical thinking he
represents thought being expressed by
questions uh
and
for him to be taken down it's crazy what
a reality what a timeline we're in
coming off of the donald trump
presidency the leader of the free world
leading the charge on critical thinking
the guy from fear factor joe rogan live
with theo vaughn
he had a contest that made people drink
special juices from horses for fifty
thousand dollars
they said that comedians were like the
the truth tellers of our edge and i
never really truly understood it until
about three years ago yeah absolutely
yeah good point make that point again
because that's an important point that
you just made the comedians are the
truth tellers of our age and there have
been like i think voltaire said if
you're gonna tell people the truth make
sure you make them laugh or they'll kill
you yeah it's just so true absolutely
that's a very good good point you
brought even powerful
militant elite authoritarians want to
laugh they're human you know and they
they love comedy i'm i'm i'm bin laden
played uh final fantasy vii i wanna just
we'll wrap this segment up with a couple
points uh i i reached out uh to joe just
you know yo what up he hasn't gotten
back to me he has no obligation to get
back to me i don't want to uh
you know abuse the fact that i know him
to to get previous information like
anything like that if he if he can't
talk about it well you know
unfortunately then he can't but i don't
know maybe he'll message me back say i
was working out or something so i will
say
it's it's really really good that his
show exists i mean it's it's really
really important the malone episode is
still up the reason we're all like
what's going on is because we recognize
how important his show is and it's
worrying to see that episodes are
getting pulled down we we need to be
able to cut through the bs thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time